[Music]
in 1999
the mars climate orbiter was destined
for fame
the first ever interplanetary weather
satellite it was designed
to study the climate and atmosphere of
the red planet
and among many other things give
scientists their first detailed
understanding of the distribution of
water
on the surface but instead on september
the 23rd
after four years of planning and 10
months of interplanetary travel
just as it began to enter the orbit of
its planetary host
all contact was lost
[Music]
mission control was instantly thrown
into confusion more than 300 million
dollars of equipment and hard work had
vanished in an instant
what could have gone wrong
an investigation was begun and on
november the 11th
the mars climate orbiter mishap
investigation board
released their findings there had been
a miscommunication in the units that had
been used to calculate
orbital insertion nasa had employed the
metric system of kilograms and meters
while an external contractor had used
the same numbers
but assumed them to be in pounds and
feet
the modern scientific world relies on
collaboration
and above all else standardization
without an absolute to measure against
chaos reigns
and orbiters disintegrate yet whatever
we choose whether it be inches
kilos or hours they are ultimately
derived from our own
existential experiences an inch is the
breadth of a man's thumb
a ketogram is about the mass of a liter
of water and an hour is a purely
subjective division of a day
here on earth but in the cosmos as a
whole
there are no men to measure there's no
water to weigh
and the concept of a day on earth means
very little
how then might an extraterrestrial
quantify its world
and how should we quantify the universe
in the most objective way
possible this was the question that
inspired the famed physicist max planck
in the final years of the 19th century
the german nobel prize winner a
professor at the friedrich vilheim
university in berlin
spent much of his academic career
contemplating how the laws of nature
could be subdivided and studied on a
minute
and discrete scale the key lay in the
physical laws of the universe themselves
while the speed that a planet goes
around its star may vary the speed of
light from that star
does not while the gravitational pull on
a large planet may differ from the
gravity on its moon
the gravitational constant that relates
mass to weight
does not so by manipulating mathematics
to set these fundamental properties of
space and time equal to one
it is possible to define fundamental
units that apply to the cosmos
regardless of where or when you happen
to be observing it
in 1899 planck revealed his calculations
to the world
the eponymous plank length measures a
minuscule 1.6 times 10 to the minus 35
meters
a decillionth of a millimeter blank time
calculated by dividing the already tiny
planck length by the very large speed of
light
is even smaller a mere 5.4 times 10 to
the minus 44 seconds long
so there are more units of planck time
in a single second
than seconds that have ever passed
while these quantities may seem
unnecessarily and pointlessly small for
our brains to comprehend
in the last century they have become
invaluable to physicists chemists and
cosmologists contemplating the remaining
mysteries of the universe
giving us the tools to understand space
and time
on the most vital scale because
observations of our universe have lent
overwhelming support to a once
outlandish theory
that the entire universe was born some
13.8 billion years ago from a minuscule
spec that expanded rapidly
exponentially the big bang
modern cosmologists have probed further
and further back through our universe's
long history to try and understand the
behavior
of matter energy and space-time itself
during these earliest moments
and they have been remarkably successful
reconstructing events
within just a tiny fraction of a second
of the big bang
and it is here at the forefront of
cosmological research
that max planck's fundamental units come
into their own
arguably the final frontier of big bang
science
scientists strive to understand what
happened when the cosmos was just one
unit of planck time long
and when it was just one planck length
in diameter
appropriately this minuscule moment has
become known as the planck
error and like other famous frontiers in
history
it is a lawless wild west for modern
physics
a place where long-held scientific
beliefs snap under the gargantuan
pressure
of a universe compressed
for in that first moment of existence
our laws of physics break down
and reveal a mind-bending world of
astonishing
possibilities
[Music]
before we can comprehend the shattering
of those laws
we must first understand what it is that
buckles
and breaks in the late 17th century
isaac newton published his seminal work
the principia mathematica within it he
proposed not only his three laws of
motion but also the universal law of
gravitation
this simple and elegant calculation
related the force of gravity to the
masses of two objects
such as a planet and a moon and the
square of the distance between them
this simple relation has become a
cornerstone of classical mechanics
and in the intervening centuries has
proven remarkably successful at
explaining the large-scale motions of
all
celestial objects
more than 200 years after newton's
principia
a young man sat doodling in a patent
office in bern in switzerland
watching the clock counterweight the
final hour of the day
becoming a patent clerk was not what he
had hoped for but after scraping through
school with a reputation for a poor
attitude
and a failed search for teaching
positions this was one of the few
options left to him
but his heart wasn't in it and even now
he sketched tiny model solar systems in
the corner of his patent applications
yearning for his true home within his
notebooks and personal mathematics
because despite his failures as a
student this man
was no fool his attitude may have been
bad but only out of impatience
his mind was alive with the great
unanswered questions in physics
his name of course was albert einstein
in 1905 he definitively threw out the
rule book of classical mechanics
in favor of a new theory this theory
which he called special relativity
described the behavior of things that
traveled close to the speed of light
fortunately for einstein his papers
found their way to the desk of max
planck himself
and with his help was able to leave the
life of a patent clerk
behind forever over the next 10 years
einstein sought to reconcile gravity
with his new framework
and the new concepts of space and time
that he had established with special
relativity
this was no easy task since newton's
universal law
already explained so much but einstein
kept at it
eventually devising another outlandish
theory
which would come to be known as general
relativity
the mathematics of general relativity
are achingly complex
but einstein's equations describe a
cosmos in which the fabric of space-time
itself
is affected by the objects within it
objects with greater mass
create curves in space-time the larger
the mass
the greater the curvature a massive star
creates a huge gravity
well and its orbiting planets are
trapped circling the curved rim of that
well
subsequent precise measurements and
experiments confirmed the validity of
this framework
including discrepancies in the orbit of
mercury
by providing the scientific world with a
new view on gravity einstein paved the
way for a truly modern
form of physics more accurate than
newton's classical mechanical approach
these heady concepts of distorted
space-time offer a much more precise and
predictive toolkit for understanding the
cosmos
solving the equations of general
relativity was what allowed the priest
come physicist george demetre to imagine
the expansion of the universe from a hot
dense state
laying the foundation for the modern big
bang theory
but even einstein's powerful
mathematical solutions
run into problems when conditions are
extreme enough
[Music]
in black holes whose mass can exceed
that of 100 billion suns concentrated
within a single point
the distortion of space-time is so great
that even light cannot escape
and eventually his exquisite mathematics
breaks down
physics may speak of infinitely small
points or infinitely high densities
but when infinity is involved
mathematical tools
can't cope and this
is key for this troublesome singularity
at the center of a black hole is similar
to the extremely dense state of the
universe during the planck error very
similar
for a fraction of a second the entire
mass of the universe was crammed into a
space 100 billion billion times
smaller than a single proton general
relativity can tell us almost everything
we want to know
about the large-scale gravitational
behavior of the universe
but it can't tell us about that first
hyper-dense moment
scientists must look elsewhere for the
answers
to the planck mystery
[Music]
traditional computers rely on tiny
transistors on integrated silicon chips
for their computing power
these transistors act like switches that
can be either on or off
and by linking millions of them together
they create the base programming for
everything that a computer can do
over the years engineers have made these
transistors ever smaller shrinking them
until they're just
5 nanometers in length the same as about
10
silicon atoms with such tiny components
the silicon chips in our pcs laptops and
smartphones are more powerful than ever
but there's a limit to how much further
we can go
any smaller and once these minuscule
tightly packed transistors are actually
put to work
strange things begin to happen
electrons belonging to a silicon atom on
one transistor
can suddenly and inexplicably jump to
another atom
on a neighboring component disrupting
the instructions passing through it
this is just one of the many mysterious
behaviors we encounter
when we're dealing with the extremely
small
as a result the next generation of
computing seeks not to overcome
these strange effects but rather to
embrace them
so-called quantum computers encode their
information not in silicon transistors
but rather in the weird particles
themselves
individual atoms or electrons have the
remarkable ability to inhabit
two discrete states at once and quantum
computers
embrace this by turning them into
switches that
like schrodinger's cat are
simultaneously on
and off until they're not
by understanding and embracing these
bizarre behaviors
quantum computing can model and
calculate complex and uncertain systems
allowing us to do things that wouldn't
be possible even with the most powerful
silicon supercomputer this new age of
computing is still in its infancy
but it relies on an entirely new physics
framework
that is already about 100 years old
the physics of the very small seem to
defy our classical experience of the
world
but it could hold the key to
understanding some of the mysteries of
the cosmos
including its very first moments around
the end of the 19th century while planck
was considering the fundamental scale of
the natural world his german colleagues
and collaborators were trying to
understand how mata behaved at these
minuscule scales
they postulated that the energy in
physical systems
such as light energy moving from a
source to a detector
did so in discrete individual packets
rather than as a continuous stream
insofar as we experience light this
proposition
seems ridiculous light behaves just as
if it were a wave
reflecting refracting spreading out and
creating interference patterns
just like waves on the ocean's surface
but under certain conditions it can
also seemingly behave like a particle
those particles are what we know as
photons
in the now famous double slit experiment
a beam of light passing through both
slits will create an
interference pattern on the other side
as would be expected for a wave
but if you detect the light as it passes
through the slits then each individual
photon passes through one or the other
not
both as a wave would thus we understand
that light can be both a particle and a
wave
at the same time once the particular
nature of light had been realized
with photons as the smallest possible
individual units of light
physicists had a new way of viewing the
physical world
they had succeeded in quantizing light
into its component photons
but that wasn't all scientists soon
realized that not just
light but all matter could be quantized
into individual
minuscule units called quantum wave
functions
based on their specific energy levels
the interaction of these quantum wave
functions determine what is and what
isn't allowed within the physical world
they are the fundamental mechanism of
the universe the reason
that anything is here at all
but just as the solutions to einstein's
general relativity equations led to some
mind-bending descriptions of curved
space-time and expanding
universes so too do the principles of
quantum mechanics
have some bizarre consequences that seem
almost
magical in the context of our everyday
experiences
quantum tunneling sees electrons
spontaneously cross physical barriers
that should stop them in their tracks
it's this phenomenon that makes the
smallest silicon computer chips behave
so strangely with electrons jumping from
transistor to transistor with no
apparent cause
elsewhere quantum fluctuations describe
the tiny random changes in the amount of
energy in a space at any one time
this is one of the weird consequences of
the so-called uncertainty principle
defined by werner heisenberg
in 1927. he discovered that certain
pairs of parameters like speed and
location
are inextricably and inversely linked
the more precisely we measure one of
them the less sure we are of the other
so we might know how fast an electron is
moving but we can't say for sure where
it is in space
quantum fluctuations are the natural
result of the uncertainty
inherent in the physical world on a
smaller scale at a particular point in
time
there might or might not be a little
extra energy
we can never say for sure so
researchers seeking to understand
quantum mechanics cannot work in
absolutes
only probabilities of course these are
the sort of problems in quantum
mechanics
that it would take a quantum computer to
solve
fortunately for gigantic creatures
reality warping quantum effects
really affect our daily lives since they
are only seen on extremely
small scales but on those scales
this new framework has given us new ways
of predicting the behavior
of matter and energy these
are the very scales that we find during
the planck era
of our cosmos and the strange behaviors
are what we would expect to encounter
when the universe
was planck-sized but
there is still a problem in the shape
of gravity the planck universe was so
dense that the effects of gravity cannot
possibly be ignored
and yet gravity is the domain of general
relativity
not quantum mechanics
physicists have tried for decades to
reconcile the two
to write the conclusive final chapter of
modern physics that can unite these
accurate
but incompatible world views and the
holy grail
of that search the final key to
unlocking the planck error
is the theory of quantum gravity
150 meters beneath the border of france
and switzerland
there is a vast concrete tunnel that
like some monstrous subterranean
auroboros
leads only back to itself in a ring 27
kilometers long the oroboros is a
fitting analogy for this immense
structure
signifying birth and death in an eternal
cycle
for this is the large hadron collider
and is the largest experiment modern
physicists have yet devised to study
some of the smallest phenomena
in the universe and understand the birth
and death
of the cosmos itself
it is a particle accelerator using
magnetic and electron fields placed at
intervals along a huge vacuum-filled
tube to accelerate protons and ions
almost
to the speed of light before smashing
them into one another
and then scrambling to interpret
patterns among the random subatomic
debris
only with such a huge and complex
facility of physicists able to generate
the high energies needed to smash
particles apart
and search for the smaller units that
define
all matter but not even the large hadron
collider
can solve the mystery of the planck
error or help in the search for the
hallowed theory of quantum gravity
by their very nature quantum
gravitational effects will only begin to
appear at planck scales
to truly understand them we need to
visualize them
but in order to shatter particles into
fragments as small as the plank length
we need to generate energies far in
excess of any that have been realized in
the large hatron collider or
elsewhere if we used a particle
accelerator
it would need to be scaled up to the
size of the entire solar system
or larger to generate the required
energies
suffice to say for now we must stick
to theoretical models
but theoretical modeling can only take
us so far
three of the four major natural forces
that permeate the universe
the strong force the weak force and the
electromagnetic force
could all be effectively described by
quantum theory
but gravity cannot the problem with
reconciling the gravitation of general
relativity with the quantum behavior of
matter
is that the two systems while internally
consistent
are fundamentally incompatible with one
another
general relativity is principally
concerned with modeling curved
space-time
while quantum field theories demand a
space-time that is unilaterally
flat what's more quantum mechanics say
that every particle has its own
intrinsic wave function
it is less a point more a smear whereas
general relativity insists that every
particle exerts a gravitational force as
a result of its distortion of space-time
but in extremely compact situations like
during the planck era the particles are
packed so closely that their wave
function smears
begin to overlap at which point even the
meaning of gravity which
notionally lies in the space between
them breaks down
to overcome these fundamental
disagreements
theoretical physicists have attempted to
define a quantum
unit of gravity a massless messenger
particle
known as a graviton which carries
gravity just as a photon
carries light but the action of gravity
is so
weak relatively speaking that such a
particle would be nion impossible
to detect other theories of quantum
gravity describe an entirely new
framework that can account for the
behavior of gravity on the quantum
scale one known as loop quantum gravity
suggests that space is composed of
planck-length scale
loops that are woven into an extremely
fine network
like an eternal hooked rug another
alternative is m theory or super string
theory
this is a favorite among physicists
seeking to unite not only general
relativity and quantum mechanics
but all modern theories of particle
physics under the so-called standard
model
in it all encompassing super strings in
11 separate dimensions may account for
all physical phenomena on all
conceivable scales
providing a theory of everything if
we could only wrap our minds around the
bulk of multi-dimensional hyperspace
if anything this is yet another problem
for the multitasking
quantum computers of the future
today physicists worldwide are
aggressively attacking the problem of
quantum gravity
offering theoretical solutions in the
form of gravitons
loop quantum gravity and super string
theory
but so far their search for this
unifying holy grail has gone
unrewarded we have many ideas of how
quantum gravity might work
but little evidence to suggest which if
any are correct
yet it is with this informed speculation
born out of centuries of study by
thousands upon thousands of scientific
giants
that we can begin to paint a picture of
the cosmos
in its very first moment
the princeton university campus sprawls
across 500 acres of the new jersey
countryside
surrounded by pine forests and salt
marshes
it is some 50 kilometers from the
atlantic coast but the long beaches of
sandy hook bay are a perfect spot
for a summer sabbatical away from the
rigours of university research
and teaching so in the summer of 1955
we can picture the pioneering
theoretical physicist
john wheeler walking along the sand his
head full of relativistic theories of
light
matter and gravity pausing to look out
across the gentle swells of the north
atlantic ocean
he follows the waves as they mount up
towards the shore and then collapse in a
turbulent seething wall of white foam
as the sea foam inches along to
overwhelm his feet to the ankles
john considers this as yet another
dynamical system
that seems to evade description the
bubbles in the foam combine
break and reform driven by complex and
chaotic force
it would be impossible to predict the
configuration
from one moment to the next a tiny spark
glimmers in the back of john wheeler's
mind
and he keeps walking that year
professor john wheeler of princeton
university published his theories
on gravitational fields in which he
argued that at the very smallest scales
the ability to even define length time
and energy
would be fundamentally compromised by
the uncertainty principle of quantum
mechanics
continuous space time would instead be
reduced to an unpredictable quantum
foam which shifted and fluctuated
randomly on the smallest possible scales
and this is the scale that defined the
beginning
of the cosmos
by combining the revelations of the last
hundred years in physics
including general relativity quantum
mechanics and the as yet unrealized
theories of quantum gravity
cosmologists can try to paint a picture
of the plank era
of our universe and it is a perplexing
one
indeed
for the first 10 million trillion
trillion trillionth of a second after
the big bang
the universe is just 10 to the minus 33
meters across 100 billion billion times
smaller
than a proton here since space-time has
yet to come into existence
time itself is undefined and space
is ultra compactified
superstring theory suggested at this
point the universe exists in no less
than 10 dimensions
which would soon collapse into a mere
four but a multi-dimensional hyperspace
is beyond the limits of our visual
imagination
and the best impressionist imagery we
can conjure is that
of john wheeler's quantum foam here
space-time folds and measures into
itself
and is meshed into quantum micro black
holes and wormholes the geometry of
space
twists and contorts instantaneously and
unpredictably
and far-flung regions of space are
connected by quantum wormholes and micro
black holes
that appear and disappear without
warning the spontaneous appearance and
disappearance of gravitons ruled by the
uncertainty principle gives space a
lumpy
and dynamic appearance there is no cause
and effect
and we can suspend all our expectations
of normal physical laws
for if anything governs here it is the
weirdness
of quantum mechanics inexplicable
quantum fluctuations
tunneling and entanglement cause space
itself to writhe
flicker and glitch like some horribly
corrupted simulation
at any one time the geometry of space is
an average of all possible geometries
theoreticians will never be able to
figure out how the history of the
universe played out before the end of
the planck era
it would be like trying to construct a
family tree
when every human alive on the planet
could be your parent
before long the randomness becomes
overwhelming the probabilities
unfeasibly small where theoreticians may
soon fail
experimental physicists never stood a
chance
even if we somehow managed to generate
the monumental energies required to
simulate quantum gravity and the
conditions during the planck era
the data would be incomprehensible
colliding gravitons or quantum loops or
super strings are expected to create
micro quantum black holes that would
immediately evaporate into a hailstorm
of random gravitons
any detection from such a collision
would find it impossible to search for
non-random patterns
to even begin to understand what is
going on
so for now we must be content with the
imagery that our current
limited physical frameworks can provide
it may not seem like much but it is a
crowning achievement of modern physics
to be able to probe the universe at such
minute scales
but perhaps by standing further back
admiring the view and trying to
understand the later periods
we may be able to find fingerprints of
the perplexing time
that came before
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like and
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
and we'll see you next time
[Music]